états unis l'objectif de vaccination
promis par dubaï donne ne sera pas
atteint le président américain on avait
fait pourtant sa priorité de sortie de
crise lors de son entrée à la maison
blanche il avait assuré que sept
américains sur dix seraient vaccinés au
4 juillet c'est le jour de la fête
nationale américaine
vous voyez la correspondance à
washington de notre journaliste thomas
bonnin la nouvelle est tombée ce mardi
mais ce n'est pas véritablement une
surprise dans les derniers chiffres
étaient annonciateurs l'objectif de 70%
de la population américaine ayant reçu
au moins une dose de vaccin ne sera pas
atteint d'ici le 4 juillet prochain une
déclaration d'un officiel de la maison
blanche à des reporters le nombre
d'injections quotidiennes se situe en ce
moment environ 850 mille doses par jour
ce qui ne permettra donc pas d'atteindre
cet objectif
un objectif qui avait été fixé en mai
par le président américain joe biden 70%
donc deux premières doses au moins et
160 millions d'américains vacciner voilà
les chiffres qui avait été annoncé par
joe biden et qui ne seront donc pas tenu
alors même si ces chiffres devraient
tout de même être atteint quelques jours
plus tard que la date fixée par joe
biden s'est tout de même un échec pour
le président qui avait fait de la lutte
contre la pandémie la priorité de son
mandat il a quand même tenu à défendre
son bilan sur twitter écouter la
déclaration de joe biden laissez moi
être clair notre programme de
vaccination est une réussite américaine
lorsque nous avons pris le pouvoir 3000
américains mourraient chaque jour
maintenant les hospitalisations ont
chuté de plus de 90%
j'exhorte les jeunes à nous faire
franchir la ligne d'arrivée en se
faisant vacciner aujourd'hui ce sont
donc principalement les jeunes que les
autorités peinent à convaincre de se
faire vacciner mais aussi de grandes
disparités entre les états clos
baelemans les états des côtes est et
ouest sont déjà l'objectif des 70%
tandis que les habitants des états plus
ruraux semble plus réfractaires à l'idée
de se faire vacciner
on rappelle qu'un certain nombre de
restrictions ont déjà été levés ici aux
etats unis comme le port du masque qui
n'est plus obligatoire pour les
personnes qui ont été vaccinées
mais des voix 5 qui est en ce moment
d'une possible nouvelle flambée
épidémique à l'automne à cause de
l'émergence de nouveaux variants et
d'une couverture vaccinale qui ne
seraient pas suffisantes